but lately you know they've excavated
some that were destroyed by earthquakes
and it turns out almost all the rooms
were used to store the pottery used to
serve feasts Wow
and that really what these things were
were places where large groups of people
came together and ate together yep and
socialized except like you know when you
when you want to punctuate time when you
want to create a sense of growth in the
life yeah you know your birth and your
death and lots of moments your marriage
your even York divorce kids kids these
things are all marked by foods that we
eat and the same thing like on the on
the rhythm of the year yeah we have
Valentine's Day of Halloween and we have
Thanksgiving come ranks giving and all
of these events are you know in some on
some level yeah they're marketing to us
and they're selling us all kinds of
often hideously unhealthy foods but what
we're doing with it is building
community yeah and building social ties
and it's a very human thing to do and
really important I remember digging up a
bowl that had been smashed in a garbage
pit and it was full of empty snail
shells what the snails went to one
person to be analyzed and the pot went
to the ceramics person and they're
interested in you know how the pottery
was treated and only in the last 20
years of they've been interested in what
it was used for yeah so it was always
the focus was on the pot it's like you
know understanding American culture by
looking at containers mm-hmm
without ever paying attention to the
stuff that's in the container soup
you know tamales tortillas so many
different variations and we're like
seeing this absolute revolution in
archaeology as people start to recognize
that
it's important you know the way that
people use the food so you know we can
tell what people ate we can tell how
much seafood they were getting in their
diet from looking at different isotope
signatures in the bone Wow we can now
get residue from the edges of stone
tools so we can tell what they were
cutting with it yeah that's crazy right
because like the fat from an animal
actually bonds with the silica in in the
tool and we now can get residue out of
pots and we can say oh they were
drinking cacao out of these pots so now
when we see a particular shape of pot we
can say yeah that's a cow drinking
vessel yeah and they're that shape
because it was foamy and they didn't
want it to overflow they liked the foam
on top yeah so you know suddenly we're
turning the tools around and using these
incredible new techniques to get so much
more information than we ever had before
and to think about how people created
social life yes you know and I think as
archaeology progresses and we're gonna
find out that there's a close
relationship between politics and hunger
yeah I think what archaeology is going
to be able to show us is what kinds of
things produce such a radical kind of
inequality that some people are willing
to stand around eating while other
people in front of them are dying of
starvation yeah